[Music]
in these days you're fighting for our
people in donbass
for this security of our motherland
russia
the 9th of may 1945
entered world history forever as a
triumph of our unified
soviet union its unity
and spiritual might
unprecedented
feats of heroism at the front and at the
home front
their victory is close to each of our's
hearts there is no family in russia
which wasn't scored by scorched by the
great patriotic war its memory doesn't
fade today
in the ranks of the immortal
regiment
grandfather great children and
great-grandchildren of those warriors
much they carry the photographs of their
forefathers who will stay forever young
and the veterans who are no longer with
us we are proud
of the
generation of victors and that were
their inheritance and our duty is to
preserve the memory of those who
defeated nazism
gave us
to be alert and to make sure that the
horror of a global war will never be
repeated and that's why despite all the
differences in international relations
russia has always
been for the creation of the security of
equal
and
reliable the security that's needed by
the whole world community in december
last year we
nato countries didn't want to hear us
and this means that in reality they had
quite different plans
and we saw that
they were openly preparing another
punitive operation
so an aggression against our historical
lands including crimea
calls in uh
kiev about the possible acquisition of
nuclear weapons the nato alliance began
to
move into their troops into our
neighboring territories and they were
creating and
an inacceptable threat to us right at
our borders everything pointed to the
fact that
clash with neo-nazis and bandera right
on who's the united states and the
minions state
was inevitable we saw them unfolding a
military infrastructures
how
hundreds of military advisers began to
work
and how regular supplies were
being made
of weapons the danger grew every day
and the russia delivered a preventive
strike against the aggressor that was a
forced timely and the only correct
decision
the decision of a sovereign strong and
independent country
address our armed forces now and the
militiamen of donbass
you are fighting for your motherland for
its future
so that nobody will forget the lessons
of the second world war so that there
will be no place in the world for
punishers and nazis today we
bow our heads to the blessed memory of
those whose lives were taken by the
great patriotic war to the memory of
sons daughters
fathers mothers
grandfathers husbands
wives
brothers sisters
relatives and friends
we bow our heads to the memory
of the
mothers of odessa who were burned alive
in the trade union building in may 19
2014 to the memory of
women and old people and children in
dunbas who died in the
under the
shelling of nazis
in the righteous battle for russia